with a face and mouth like a muppet some
might think this bard tiger salamander
is cute but to insect passers-by that
mouth is deadly this salamander with
enough camouflage markings on its body
- almost blend into the surrounding
foliage - an unsuspecting passing insect
can quietly stalk and wait for the
moment with a quick opening of the mouth
it captures its prey and with another
quick opening and gulp it then swallows
its victims even though they can grow to
over a foot long and are the largest
land dwelling salamanders in the world
they are hard to find and they are
mostly active at night when it's harder
for us to see them these amphibians only
have four toes on their front feet and
five toes on their back feet and they
can live up to 20 years
besides insects and earthworms these
salamanders can also eat small mice and
smaller and fibia pnes like frogs they
even cut down on some of the nighttime
noise by chomping down on a cricket
every now and then they live in places
where they can stay cool and moist and
they require water to lay their eggs
they spend a lot of their time in
underground burrows sometimes borrowing
the homes of crayfish or even prairie
dogs tiger salamanders can be found
throughout North America
but the barred tiger salamander is only
found in a smaller range from Nebraska
to northeastern Mexico and in Kansas
they are the official state amphibian